how Selena Gomez really feels about
Justin Bieber's engagement and gasp
Kylie Jenner is embracing her real pal
Plus Tiffany Haddish gets emotional over
her new car hey guys I'm Denny direct Oh
this is the daily Denny and I missed you
during look tanner you took a couple
days off but came back to the most
unexpected headline of the year Justin
Bieber is engaged and oh I did not see
this coming did you guys the Biebs
popped the question or girlfriend Haley
Baldwin in the Bahamas a source tells ET
Justin got down on one knee and asked
Bailey to marry him but not before he
requested that everyone in the
restaurant not take any photos or video
we're told Haley was smiling from ear to
ear and said yes and is over the moon
with joy and now we have a glimpse of
what could be Haley's and Gabe EURion
guys check out this rock if you had any
doubts Bieber Whisperer ill that massive
hardware right there says it all
now the question I'm sure on the minds
of a lot of Jelena fans
how did Justin's excellent Lena Gomez
take the news well a source tells us she
does not care at all okay our source
adds that Selena's in a great place and
quote what they do with their life does
not impact her Justin and Haley's
happiness doesn't take away from her own
happiness all right what do you guys
make of Justin and Haley surprise
engagement I just hope you get the damn
haircut before the wedding
speaking of changing appearances looks
like the queen of the lip kit Kylie
Jenner is going back to basics Kylie
Jenner posted this shot celebrating
eight years of friendship with Stassi
but fans were quick to notice that
something about Kylie had changed now
can you spot the difference here is
Kylie from just seven weeks ago and this
is Kylie now she looks a bit more
natural it's because she got rid of her
lip fillers commenters pointed out how
Kylie had more natural looking lips and
wrote she looks like the old Kylie
which was spot on because the new mom
revealed yep she went on natural no mo
Phyllis and it looks like Kylie's new
old book is a hit since her Chloe posted
three fire emojis and good friend hailey
Baldwin justice Beyonce
so beautiful I don't know about you guys
but I think she looks so pretty right
let us know which big alright listen I
think it's safe to say that nobody had a
better weekend and Tiffany Haddish the
girls trip star got the surprise of a
lifetime when Tyler Perry gifted her
with a brand new Tesla and our Courtenay
tez know heard all about the special
gift from Tiffany herself at an evening
with Tiffany Haddish
for Hollywood confidential panel series
Tyler Perry we saw that he went ahead
and got you a Tesla you as someone that
has lived out of their car and has come
this far and Tyler he's someone who
believed in you tell me your initial
reaction because I thought you get a
little emotional
okay he sent me the video a week ago and
I was like I feel like and I cried so I
cried so hard because you know crying is
nothing but a removal of all beliefs and
a replacement of new ones right and it
was a belief said like oh somebody will
do something nice for you just because
you are you you know and and I always
had a belief that if somebody wants to
do something I have to do like a
thousand nice things I have to be really
nice in order for somebody to do
something nice to me and I just did my
job it's the best of my capacity and if
for him to be that kind to me and not
expect anything from me but what I've
already given like that like it filled
my whole heart up and then when I saw
the car for real life-like cuz I thought
it was a joke at first I was like I'm a
cry off this job but like Demi was real
it's real
it was real and imminent some new
friends okay you know tiffany has talked
about living out of her car when she was
just starting out and told us back if
she ends up losing everything tomorrow
she's gonna be the best homeless person
and the bomb is Tesla and I heard that
okay guys that's it we'll be back
tomorrow with another dose of the daily
Deni in the meantime be sure to check
out more from our interview with Tiffany
where she dishes on her biggest splurge
since making a big i'll see you guys
tomorrow